Wir sprechen jetzt über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da sind 6 Spieltage gespielt und es sieht ganz gut aus für die einen Teams und bei anderen wurden schon die Träne entlassen. Wir sprechen jetzt drüber mit einem Fokus auf Fortuna Düsseldorf und den 1. FC Nürnberg, mit Fadi Keblawi vom Kadeb Podcast und nn.de und mit Gianni Koster, chefreporter Sport bei der Rheinischen Post, jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier ist der Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich freue mich, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Und ich freue mich, endlich mal wieder hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Gianni Kostat, Gianni, schön, dass du da bist.
Hi Max, grüß dich auch.
Schön, dass ich eingeladen wurde. Ja, keine Ahnung, warum das so lange gedauert hat. Aber so ist das ja manchmal. Ich glaube, haben wir uns bei der EM gesehen schon? Oder das bitte ich mir nicht ein, dass wir uns da getroffen haben.
Wir haben uns quasi auf die Hand gestreichelt. So nahe saßen wir beieinander in München.
Ach, in München war das ja. Genau, genau, genau.
Ich glaube nicht nur in München, wir waren auch in einer anderen Stadt, dass du eine Frage gestellt hast, über die ich erst mal eine halbe Stunde nachdenken musste. Das war in Nürnberg. Genau, da haben wir uns auch noch im Vorfeld der EM gesehen.
Aber auf der PK habe ich… Ach so, ah, auf der Pressekonferenz. Ja, da durfte ich ja noch Fragen stellen. Bei der EM bin ich ja nicht rangekommen. Aber gut, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Uefa, Mafia, durch und durch. Aber das kläre ich off the record. Ich freue mich aber, dass on the record hier Fadi Keblawi ist. Fadi, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo ihr beiden. Mich interessiert jetzt natürlich, was war die Frage, über die man eine halbe Stunde nachdenkt. Also würde ich jetzt auch gerne.
Das hatte so eine grausame Tiefe, die nur der Max in der Lage ist zu stellen. Ich bin da einfach viel zu oberflächlicher Typ. Und das war aber was, was mir imponiert hat, weil er natürlich aber auch mit Julian Nagelsmann dann quasi Pendant gefunden hat, der aber auch so eine Frage beantworten kann. Das ist ja ganz, ganz oft so. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch beiden geht, dass man immer angemahnt bekommt von Fußball-Trainern, man möge doch über Fußball mit ihnen reden. Dann will man mit ihnen über Fußball reden und dann wollen sie aber dann doch nicht so mit einem über Fußball reden. Das ist ein Paradoxum, was mir schon ganz oft aufgefallen ist. Und deswegen fand ich es schön, dass da wirklich, wenn man so will, ob es jetzt eine diepe Frage war oder nicht, sei dahingestellt. Aber es war auf jeden Fall eine Frage, die schon auf Fußballkompetenz abzielte. Und Julian Nagelsmann ist halt eben auch drauf eingestiegen. Also von daher fand ich es dann am Ende ein Win-Win für beide, ohne jetzt zu sehr da jetzt Lobhudeleien in welche Richtung auch immer abgeben zu wollen. Es war einfach gut.
Und oft genug versanden diese Fragen auch. Also ich habe über mehrere Pressekonferenzen immer versucht, aus Thomas Tuchel mal ein bisschen mehr rauszubekommen. Und er hat immer nur so die Standardantworten gegeben, wo ich auch einfach hätte fragen können, wie fanden Sie das Spiel? Und dann fragt ihn ein englischsprachiger Journalist beim Spiel gegen Arsenal, ja, sie haben ja sich gegen 4-4-2 entschieden, sondern 4-2-3-1. Was sind denn Ihre Gedanken dazu? Und er setzt an zu 10 Minuten Monolog allgemein über diese Systeme. Und ich denke mir so, Thomas, Herr Tuchel, das wollte ich die ganze Zeit hören. Aber gut, so ist es halt. Lasst uns über die zweite Liga sprechen, denn das ist ja das eigentliche Thema. Und wenn ich jetzt nach sechs schon gespielten Spieltagen da auf die Tabelle blicke, gibt es manches überraschende. Und wir haben ja auch schon den ersten Trainerwechsel. Fadi, was würdest denn du sagen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt nicht so tief drin waren die letzten zwei Wochen? Was sind denn so die wichtigsten Geschichten, die passiert sind?
Natürlich Schalke, Chaos, wobei ich nicht weiß, ob die Menschen nicht daran gewohnt sind, gewöhnt sind und eh damit rechnen, dass irgendwann relativ…
Ich hatte nach überraschenden Dingen gefragt.
Ja, dann tatsächlich ein bisschen überrascht bin ich, dass Magdeburg so weit oben mitmacht, wobei ich glaube, dass ich sie in meinem Saison-Tipp auch relativ weit oben einklassiert habe, aber das finde ich gut, dass die Fortuna, wenn wir über die heute sprechen, dass die dieses Relegationsdrama so gut weggesteckt hat, auch ziemlich cool und der 1. FC Nürnberg auch eine Überraschung, aber eben nicht so schön im Sinne. Aber ich bin hier, glaube ich, sowieso noch nie zu Gast gewesen und konnte irgendwas Nettes über den 1. FC Nürnberg sagen. Also die Tradition setze ich heute fort.
Ich möchte aber betonen, dass das nicht am Rasenfunk liegt.
Nein, das ist einzig und allein die Schuld des 1. FC Nürnberg.
Ich wäre offen auch für sehr positive Themen. Aber da kommen wir dazu. Ja, Tadi, sind das so die wichtigsten Themen? Oder was würdest du sagen ist gerade noch so wichtig mitzubekommen?
Ja, absolut. Ich glaube, da hat Fadi einen relativ guten Rundumschlag gemacht. Das wären jetzt auch so meine Top-News zur 2. Liga gewesen. Ist tatsächlich, finde ich, eine Saison, die schon ziemlich schnell auf Betriebstemperatur gekommen ist, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen, jetzt nicht nur wegen Trainer-Entlassungen. Die es ja schon gab, sondern eben auch Nürnberg mit einem, ja, sehr prominenten Namen dann an den Start gegangen mit großen Zielen. Komme sicherlich später dann noch zu. Und Düsseldorf tatsächlich nach Spieltag 6 jetzt immer noch oben an der Spitze. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Da müssen wir gleich darüber sprechen. Ich meine, es hat ja einen Grund, dass ich gerade euch beide eingeladen habe und diese beiden Vereine nochmal näher besprechen möchte. Was denkt ihr denn, wenn ihr auf den Tabellen Keller blickt? Also wir sind es ja gewohnt, dass das sehr gestaucht ist in der 2. Liga. Aber jetzt hat Braunschweig seinen Sieg gesammelt, Regensburg hat gewonnen. Also wir haben kein Team, was so richtig quasi abreißen lässt. Der Mix ist schon noch– weiß nicht Fadi, ob du da vielleicht auch aus Sicht des Clubs, der ja mit sieben Punkten– wollen sie sich überbewerten– sechs Spieltage schon klar. Aber schon ganz schön interessant, was da unten drin wieder passiert. Schon wieder.
Ja, zu interessant für den ersten FC Nürnberg. Ich dachte so vor der Saison, dass es mit Regensburg, Ulm, Braunschweig, Münster auf jeden Fall vier Mannschaften gibt, die diese drei Abstiegs- bzw. Traditionsplätze unsersich ausmachen. Ich bin noch nicht ganz vom Gegenteil überzeugt, aber ich habe jetzt natürlich auch den Braunschweigers Sieg gegen die Spielvereinigung Fürth mitbekommen, weil die uns einfach auch in der Redaktion relativ nahe sind als Nachbarverein. Die Spielvereinigung hatte jetzt sehr lange nicht mehr verloren, Saisonübergreifend und hatte dann in Braunschweig gar keine Chance. Also ja, spannend, auch für den ersten FC Nürnberg da unten.
Aber auch schon spannend, wie viel Drama da schon in diese Liga rein interpretiert wird oder in diese Tabelle. Wie gesagt, nochmal Spieltag 6 und wenn man sieht, Köln und ja auch Nürnberg liegen jetzt ja auch nicht Lichtjahre auseinander, nach oben hin. Klar, da gibt es schon ein, zwei Punkte, die dann weggeflogen sind. Aber mir ist das gerade noch alles ein bisschen zu überhitzt, auf der einen oder anderen Seite.
Wobei, wenn ich ganz kurz aus Nürnbergs Sicht, ist es so, dass dieses Drama-Gefühl seit zehn Jahren stattfindet, hier in Nürnberg. Und deshalb glaube ich, alle nach Spieltage 1 schon on fire waren und sind, weil alle hier in Nürnberg befürchten, es geht so weiter wie in den vergangenen Saisons. Und vielleicht ist es an manch anderen Standorten auch so, dass es inzwischen auch alle Saison übergreifend gesehen wird.
Ja, und ich glaube, gleichzeitig, was zu so einer Nervosität führt, die auch nachvollziehbar ist, ist, die 2. Liga war schon immer unberechenbarer als die 1. Liga. Und das zeigt sich in der Saison auch wieder. Du kannst nicht damit rechnen, dass jemand, ohne Sieg zu haben in den ersten zehn Spieltagen, dahin fleucht. Sondern jeder holt mal so seinen überraschenden Sieg, der dann irgendwie in der Rückschau dann doch nicht so überraschend ist. Aber das macht es halt so interessant, dass eben dann Ulm gewinnt in Elversberg und auf einmal jetzt bei vier Punkten steht. Dann das Braunschwerk gewinnt gegen Fürth. Das haben wir schon. Das Münster gewinnt in Regensburg. So kommt das eben. Und ich verstehe total, was du sagst, Gianni. Und wir wissen ja auch, wichtig wird quasi die Serien, die man startet. Und da ist es vielleicht sogar besser, die erst im Frühjahr zu haben und nicht jetzt schon. Aber es ist schon interessant, dass das einfach so weitergeht, wie in der letzten Saison auch. So richtig abschreiben kann man niemand. Also gut, da gab es einen klaren Absteiger, aber dann wird es ja sehr eng. Spannende Liga. Und da haben wir ja über den HSV und Paderborn zum Beispiel noch gar nicht gesprochen. Oder Hannover. Ach Gott, man müsste eigentlich härter. Meine Güte, was müsste man alles sprechen. Aber wir beschränken uns heute mal auf das und blicken vor allem jetzt mal auf Fortuna Düsseldorf genauer. Denn Fadi hat ja die Einleitung quasi schon gegeben, Gianni. Letztes Jahr dieses Relegationsdrama. Und ich habe eigentlich keine Saisonvorschau gehört oder gelesen, in der man davon ausgegangen war. Na, die stecken das jetzt ganz einfach weg. Und starten ungeschlagen in diese Saison hinein. Jetzt ist aber genau das passiert. Wobei man sagen muss, eine bittere Niederlage gab es dann natürlich doch in der ersten Runde bei Dynamo Dresden. Was war denn das jetzt für ein Saisonstart für die Fortuna?
Ja, am Ende war es bisher ein Saisonstart, mit dem man sich unfassbar viel Zeit erkauft hat. So habe ich es jetzt ein, zwei Mal versucht, schon in Analysen zu formulieren für diese Saisonbestimmung, weil aus unserer Sicht glaube ich erst so Richtung Winter klar wird, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist jetzt eine sehr, sehr im Grundstock eingespielte Mannschaft, die fast ohne Verletzungen in die Saison gestartet ist, bis auf Vincent Fermet, der jetzt auch wieder zurückgekehrt ist, und Jamil Siebert, der sich gerade zurückkämpft. Sind die weitestgehend verschont geblieben. Das war ja in der vergangenen Saison deutlich anders. Da gab es schon mal etliche Monate, wo man sich nicht ganz sicher war, mit welcher Elf man da überhaupt noch auflaufen wollte. Tatsächlich, drei Unterschiedsspieler sind gegangen mit Christos Choulis, mit Aotanaka und Yannick Engelhardt. Für mich persönlich, Yannick Engelhardt, sogar eigentlich der heftigste Verlust, weil der so ein bisschen, ja, das Herz dieser Mannschaft so war im Mittelfeld. Der hat da sehr viel intelligent weggeschrubbt, was man jetzt teilweise merkt, wo man deutlich mehr Probleme hat, deutlich mehr Aufwand betreiben muss, um das Gleiche zu erreichen. Aber das Grundgerüst der Mannschaft ist stehen geblieben. Und ich glaube, aus meiner Sicht, jetzt beobachte die 2. Liga ja jetzt auch wieder seit 3, 4 Jahren mit Fortuna ein bisschen intensiver, dass das wirklich das Schlüsselthema ist in der 2. Liga, Kontinuität. Also da eine Mannschaft zu haben, die eingespielt ist, die wirklich weiß, worauf es ankommt, ist da das A und O viel, viel, viel wichtiger, als so jetzt diesen XY-Schlüsselspieler unbedingt dabei zu haben. Der ist natürlich dann nach hinten raus, siehe Christos Choulis und seine Scorer-Punkte dann auch sehr hilfreich. Aber so das Gesamtkonstrukt ist eigentlich aus meiner Sicht mit entscheidender. Weil wenn man da einfach zu viel Zeit braucht, um eine Mannschaft erstmal einspielen zu lassen, dann verliert man auf Strecke zu viel Zeit und Punkte und steht dann am Ende da mit dem Rücken zur Wand und muss irgendwelche Harakiri-Aufholjagden dann noch machen. Klar, du hast es eben angesprochen, Max. Liga, sehr, sehr viel, auch gerade letzte Saison wiedergesehen. Mit Serien ist da viel, viel noch zu holen. Aber noch mal, kostet halt eben auch Kraft und momentan sieht es so aus, dass Düsseldorf da zumindestens auf einem guten Weg ist.
Aber wenn du das jetzt so betont, dass das Gerüst geblieben ist, spielen denn dann Neuzugänge dann trotzdem jetzt schon eine Rolle oder sind das andere Spieler, die da so ein bisschen in die Bresche gesprungen sind?
Teils, teils. Also es ist so, dass Daniel Thune bezogen jetzt auf die letzten Spiele– ja, ich glaube ich, jetzt will nicht lügen– drei oder drei Spiele, glaube ich, mit exakt der gleichen Startelf angefangen hat, wo dann der Kern schon Spieler sind, die auch in der vergangenen Saison schon da waren. Als Überraschung vielleicht Tim Rossmann, der lange verletzt war in Karlsruhe davor, ist dazugekommen, Danny Schmidt hat auch als Neuzugang gespielt. Gut, David Kovenacki ist zurückgekommen aus Bremen. Also diese drei sind dann in die Mannschaft geperrt, aber dazu sind dann viele auch überraschende Personalien gekommen. Beispielsweise so ein Dauerbrenner, den man wahrscheinlich, wenn man auch nur die 2. Liga so ein bisschen am Rande verfolgt, im Namensgedächtnis hat, Matthias Zimmermann, genannt Zimbo, der ist als normaler Rechtsverteidiger jetzt in die Mitte gerutscht, um damit seine Erfahrung auszuhelfen. Also momentan wird ein bisschen auch versucht, mit eigenen Bordmitteln zu experimentieren und bis die Zugänge so weit sind, dass sie das Spielsystem von Daniel Thun verstanden haben, also die noch übrig gebliebenen Zugänge, ja, dass man da versucht, ein bisschen mit der Karte Erfahrung das Wettz zu machen, weil man eben nicht eins zu eins Ersatz realisieren konnte. Also es gibt keinen klassischen Jules Ersatz, es gibt keinen klassischen Aotanaka Ersatz, es gibt keinen Janik Engelhardt Ersatz. Da gibt es zwar Namen, die nachgerückt sind, aber selbst Daniel Thun hat jetzt unlängst nach dem Köln Derby sehr offen gesagt, dass das nicht die gleiche Qualität ersetzt. Sondern dass er sich jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen umstellen muss, einfach sein Spielsystem auch umstellen muss, um sich dann sozusagen an die personellen Gegebenheiten anzupassen.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt die Ergebnisse angucke, dann sieht das sehr ähnlich aus zur letzten Saison. Nämlich ist es sehr stabil, also zum Auftakt in Darmstadt gewonnen, 0-0 gegen Kaisrú und man hatte schon relativ viele Gegner, wo ich sagen würde, das sind Mitausstiegsaspiranten. Also Ulm, klammern wir da aus, aber Hannover, Hertha, Köln, gegen keinen von denen verloren. Jetzt Köln, das war ein Unentschieden, den Rest alles gewonnen. Sehr häufig zu Null, erst drei Gegentreffer in sechs Spielen. Hat sich denn am Spielstil was verändert oder ist Fortuna der Saison 23-24 mit der Saison 24-25 sehr vergleichbar?
Also sie stehen schon einen Ticken tiefer jetzt. Also sie haben sich, was die Defensive angeht, sind sie schon abwartender. Also sie können aber auch viel aushalten. Sie haben da viel Erfahrung drin stehen. Gut, ich habe ja eben schon versucht zu sagen oder zu relativieren, wie ich eine Tabelle interpretiere, jedenfalls in meiner Person. Weißt du, wenn du die Mannschaften jetzt durchgehst und damit will ich überhaupt nicht nur im Ansatz schmälern, was da geleistet wurde. Ich will nur sagen, es hat natürlich auch immer was mit einem Timing zu tun, wann du auf wen da triffst. Hertha BSC beispielsweise war noch so unfassbar oder ist noch gerade mit sich beschäftigt. Vielleicht wird es auch wieder die ganze Saison andauern. Vielleicht wird man den Turnover wie letztes Jahr schaffen, wo man ja dann auch noch mal eine Serie gestartet hat. Andere Mannschaften, bei denen ist es ähnlich, wo ich glaube, wenn da einmal der Motor richtig rollt, wird das auch anders aussehen. Deswegen ist ja das so wichtig, was ich eben gesagt habe. Umso mehr oder höher ist es hier einzuschätzen, was man jetzt halt eben einfach für Punkte dann schon eingesammelt hat. Aber ich denke, wenn man die Mannschaft durchgeht, beispielsweise auf Florian Kastenmeier Blick, den Torwart, dann muss man einfach sagen, da ist ein so unfassbar gereifter Mensch zwischen den Pfosten mittlerweile. Ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich ja. Ob er jetzt zu den Top-3-Torhütern der 2. Liga gehört, das ist am Ende dann auch immer ein bisschen Geschmackssache. Ich finde sowieso, dass er am Fuß auf jeden Fall einer der besten Torhüter in Deutschland ist. Ganz klar, was der in der Spieleröffnung kann, da hast du im Prinzip immer ständig eine Überzahl-Situation, wenn der sich mit nach vorne sozusagen einschaltet. Das ist sicherlich ein Punkt. Der hat ein, zwei Punkte mindestens diese Saison schon festgehalten. Er hatte davor, in den Jahren davor, immer mal wieder auch so einen Kullerball, der reingegangen ist. Also der ist deutlich reifer, deutlich stabiler geworden in seinen Handlungen. Dazu, du hast, wie gesagt, unfassbar viel Erfahrung davor. Hast zwei, drei auch gefühlte Zugänge. Nicolas Gavoury beispielsweise, der Franzose auf der linken Abwehrseite, hat unterirdische Auftritte zum Teil in der vergangenen Saison auch hingelegt. Hatte jetzt eine lange Verletzung hinter sich und jetzt in den ersten Spielen wirklich richtig aufgeblüht. Hat richtig Spaß gemacht, dem zuzugucken, sehr, sehr mutig gespielt. Und das sind natürlich dann Möglichkeiten wieder für den Trainer, ja, auch zu verschieben, andere Optionen zu benutzen im spieltaktischen Bereich, für Entlastung zu sorgen möglicherweise und dann dementsprechend das Spiel auch so zu gestalten, dass dann da am Ende, wie du schon gesagt hast, drei Gegentore stehen und neun geschossene Tore. Also insgesamt schon ein sehr stabiler Auftritt für die ersten sechs Spiele. Vor allen Dingen aber auch, das hat man jetzt gesehen, in Klammern natürlich mit den Wermutstropfen, DFB-Pokal, auch das hast du eben schon angesprochen, dass die Mentalität in der Mannschaft aber unfassbar stark zu sein scheint, nicht nur wegen diesem 2 zu 2 gegen Köln in letzter Sekunde quasi. Gibt es auch noch so zwei, drei andere Situationen, wo man immer wieder das Gefühl hat, da hat sich schon eine Gruppe gefunden im Grand, die halt irgendwas zusammen erreichen will. Und die eben, um nochmal den Bogen zu spannen zur letzten Saison, das schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr getroffen hat. In Klammern, ich glaube, den Trainer hat es am allermeisten getroffen, was da in der Relegation gegen Bochum passiert ist. Aber natürlich auch viele der Spieler, die aber gesagt haben, okay, neuer Anlauf, eine neue Chance für den ein oder anderen, die erste Chance für den, ja, für ein paar andere, dann wiederum die letzte Chance, jetzt nochmal wirklich da oben anzuklopfen. Deswegen, das ist die Gemengelage.
Ich würde da gerne mal die Meinung von Fadi dazu holen. Ich weiß ja, dass du auch schon seit vielen Jahren die 2. Liga genau verfolgst. Wie denkst du denn darüber, wenn du jetzt auch siehst, wie gelassen Gianni spricht und wie zurückhaltend, wie bremsend er fast schon ist? Da kenne ich ja andere Vereine, da wäre der Hypetrain im Aller so richtig am Rollen.
Es ist erstmal der pure Neid. Ich habe gerade während dieser Ausführungen überlegt, wann ich das letzte Mal über den 1. FC Nürnberg so wohlwollend und bremsend habe sprechen dürfen. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass Fortuna…
Fadi, das kann bei uns in 3 Wochen auch wieder anders sein.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich wollte gerade sagen, Fortuna steigt auf. Das ist damit klar, gemeinsam mit dem KSC oder sowas. Ich bin ja hier auch für die Prognosen. Und deshalb sensationell. Das ist wirklich was… Ich habe Angst vor den 10 Minuten, in denen ich dann über den 1. FC Nürnberg sprechen soll, weil dann kommen hinterher wieder die Menschen und sagen, der Keblawi kann auch nur negativ. Aber es ist schön, dir zuzuhören und der Fortuna zuzusehen. Zumal ich auch Freunde habe, die Fortuna-Fans sind, denen gönne ich es noch sehr viel mehr.
Fadi, damit es nicht zu unheimlich wird, lass mich nur noch mal unterstreichen. Ich habe es eben schon mal versucht zu sagen, ich gucke Richtung Weihnachten. Dann traue ich mir wirklich zu, zu sagen, wohin die Reise geht. Jetzt ist es wirklich für mich, für den Verein, für viele, die es mit der Fortuna halten, eine superschöne Momentaufnahme. Und warum nicht? Soll es auch noch weiter so gehen? Es spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen. Tatsache ist aber auch, dass es gerade wirklich ideal läuft. Dass alle Situationen, wo man am Ende gefühlt wie gegen Köln, eigentlich– es gibt es auch niemanden, der das bestreitet– ein verdienter Verlierer gewesen wäre, dann noch diesen Punkt holt, den man, wenn man dann diesen Lauf hat, eben auch holt. Aber es gibt jetzt keine größeren Verletzungs-Sorgen, es gibt keine größeren Formtiefs. Das sind die Dellen in der Saison, wo du wirklich dann die Relienz zum Vorschein kommt, ob du jetzt eben eine Spitzenmannschaft bist oder nicht. Kannst du dich dagegen stemmen, wenn dies, das Ananas passiert? Und deswegen jetzt gerade auf dieser Welle, die ich, wie gesagt, gerade auch den Leid geprüften Düsseldorfern, die ja mit so vielen anderen Traditionsvereinen die gleiche Geschichte letztendlich teilen, den gönne ich es wirklich, Spieltag für Spieltag da oben zu stehen. Realistisch gesehen, nochmal, was ich eben versucht habe zu sagen, die drei Zugänge sind einfach nicht adäquat ersetzt worden. Das heißt, dass ein Tim Rossmann zurzeit überperformt, finden alle fantastisch. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange er das durchhält, rein körperlich gesehen. Das kennen wir alle, dass es da auch immer wieder Probleme gibt. Also nochmal, ich will überhaupt nicht unken. Für uns ist es tatsächlich auch eine ungewohnte Situation in Düsseldorf, dass wir mal so nach oben blicken und uns fast selber die Augen reiben. Aber man muss halt eben auch positiv sagen, es sind halt eben in den vergangenen Jahren viele richtige Entscheidungen auch getroffen worden. Nichtsdestotrotz gilt es da– von mir aus bin ich da auch der Chefbremser– geht es darum, so ein bisschen auf die Bremse zu drücken und nicht da völlig jetzt zu überdrehen. Weil was wir da jetzt auch gesehen haben, ist nicht Real Düsseldorf oder so, sondern das war jetzt alles sehr nüchtern, was da abgeliefert wurde. Am Ende mit einem tollen Punkteergebnis. Aber es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass die da jetzt brasilianisch irgendwie die zweite Liga gerade zusammen spielen, sondern das ist sehr, sehr sachlich korrekter Fußball mit einem guten Ergebnis. Und ja, noch ein, zwei Länderspiel-Pausen später wissen wir mehr.
Ja, akzeptiere ich. Aber man muss schon anerkennen, nach dem Ende der vergangenen Saison ist das schon eine Leistung einer Mannschaft und auch eines Trainers, dann so in die neue Saison zu starten. Also ich glaube, das ist nicht so vielen Mannschaften in den letzten Jahren, in den letzten Jahren, die Lührungen, dass sie nach einer verlorenen Relegation dann gleich wieder so okay performen.
Total, aber wenn du bei uns die Stimmung gesehen hättest, das war ja das Faszinierende, nach den ersten beiden Spielen, da war unfassbar viel Druck auf dem Kessel. Daniel Thun, wenn du den da gesehen hättest, uiuiui, der ist richtig auf Anschlag gewesen, weil er auch selber nicht wusste, wohin die Reise geht. Das war ja, wie gesagt, durch diese harten Einschnitte in den Kader schon so eine absolute Wundertüte, wohin die Reise geht. Und man sieht aber, das ist einfach das Faszinierende am Fußball, wie schnell Wunden heilen können, wenn halt eben sportliche Erfolge da sind. Die können halt so so viel auch an Entwicklungsschritten verkürzen, die jetzt in anderen Bereichen, vielleicht hier bei Schalke und bei anderen Clubs, die jetzt weiter unten stehen, jetzt viel, viel länger dauern werden. Alleine dadurch, dass die Schalke jetzt da einen Trainerwechsel vollzogen werden musste, mal wieder. Dadurch verliert man halt Zeit, dadurch gewinnt man nie Zeit. Und das sind halt eben Punkte, die in Düsseldorf gut gelaufen sind. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, wenn es irgendwas gibt, woran man den Erfolg festmachen kann, dann ist es vor allen Dingen eben Daniel Thun, der einfach, keine Ahnung, es hört sich so arg Fanboy-mäßig an, aber der schon echt ein Glücksfall für Fortuna ist, weil der halt eben nicht nur offensichtlich einen guten Draht zur Mannschaft hat und irgendwie seine Spielidee da vernünftig verkauft, sondern eben halt auch, was die Kommunikation angeht, diesem Verein so viel wie so ein Staubsauger da wegsaugt, was dann vielleicht an anderen Standorten zu einem Problem hochploppen könnte. Das ist eigentlich ein Wert, den kann man nicht hoch genug einschätzen. Also da kann man nur sagen, auch wenn es für uns manchmal dann ein bisschen zäh wird, was die Berichterstattung angeht, weil er so gar keine Angriffsfläche bietet, ist es dann schon was, wo ich sagen muss, Wahnsinn, wie eloquent sachlich der da immer wieder auf Dinge eingeht, weil er auch die Probleme selber sieht, nicht davor die Augen verschließt, sondern offensiv auch anspricht. Ja, und so ist dann halt eben auch eine Entwicklung möglich für alle Seiten, ohne dass da jetzt so eine Bombe im Hintergrund tickt.
Da merkt man, glaube ich, auch die Erfahrung. Ich meine, Daniel Thun hat eben einfach auch schon einiges erlebt und weiß dann, glaube ich, auch, wie wichtig das auch ist in gewissen Situationen, selbst wenn es in einem selber vielleicht brodelt oder man gerade einiges Kritisches zu sagen, hätte, dann auch zu beruhigen. Ich fand auch, dass das rund um die Relegation wirklich bemerkenswert war, wie Daniel Thun sich da verhalten hat. Vielleicht ist es schon ein kurzer Vorgriff auf Club-Segment, aber wie ist denn Miroslav Klose in der Außendarstellung, Fadi, im Vergleich dazu?
Es ist ein sehr selbstkritischer Mensch, ein sehr ehrlicher, was man, glaube ich, auch in diesem Business eher selten findet, aber auch einigermaßen unsicher, was so öffentliche Auftritte betrifft. Gerade Pressekonferenzen und Journalistengespräche ist jetzt nicht so sein allerliebstes, glaube ich, aber er macht es mit aufrichtigkeit. Und er ist natürlich bei den Fans in Nürnberg immer noch unfassbar beliebt und nimmt sich nach den öffentlichen Trainingseinheiten wirklich für jeden Zuschauer, jede Zuschauerin Zeit und Autogramme schreiben. Wir haben in den Ferien mal– da musste er zehn Meter zu uns wartenden Journalisten zurücklegen und hat dafür tatsächlich 32 Minuten gebraucht, weil jeder ein Selfie machen wollte und so was. Und das macht er aber auch ohne irgendwelche Allüren und cool und so. Aber so was dieses Fußball fachlich sachliche betrifft, da ist es in der Außendarstellung bei ihm manchmal noch so ein bisschen wenig.
Ja, interessant, das so zu hören.
Ja, aber Berufsanfänger eben. Also das mag sein, dass sich das noch ändert, auch um dem schon mal vorzugreifen. Ich habe meine Zweifel daran, dass es ihm im Nürnberg gelingen wird.
Also ich habe eine Wette auf Miro Klose, dass er die Saison schafft. Ich muss sagen, gerade stehe ich so ein bisschen mit dem Rücken zur Wand. Ich gebe es zu, aber du siehst, ich versuche das Team-Optimismus hier hochzuhalten.
Schwierig, sehr schwierig.
Ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz Max ergänzen oder dann vielleicht auch noch mal den Ball zurückspielen, Richtung Daniel Thun, weil du gesagt hast, dass ihm so eine Erfahrung auszeichnet. Um das ein bisschen zu relativieren, was man bei ihm merkt, ist tatsächlich, dass er super vorsichtig geworden ist. Er hat in Osnabrück ja ein sehr familiäres Umfeld gehabt, kommt daher und ist ja dann irgendwann, weil er sich so ein bisschen auch abnabeln wollte und die große Welt auch mal schmecken wollte, zum HSV gegangen und hat da sozusagen die böse Seite des Fußballs, sind jetzt meine Worte, nicht seine, kennengelernt und hat vielleicht mit seiner Art, mit seiner offenen Art, auch manchmal zu viel Offenheit zugelassen für dieses Geschäft, ist dann aus Hamburg über den Umweg Sky Experte, wo er glaube ich super viel auch aufgesaugt hat, was so die Medienlandschaft angeht, dann nach Düsseldorf gekommen und hat da einfach eine sehr klare Struktur, also er ist da jemand, der sagt, er ist zu offiziellen Zeiten anlässend immer ansprechbar, darüber hinaus aber eigentlich nicht. Es gibt ja bei uns im Rheinland gab es da auch schon mal andere Mentalitäten, die wir da hatten, aber das ist ja sehr, sehr klar. Ansonsten aber ist es so, dass natürlich man auch merkt, dass er noch ein Trainer ein Stück weit in Ausbildung ist, in allem, was er macht. Also beispielsweise Relikationsrückspiel gegen Bochum, das war fast schon, man wollte ihn eigentlich so an ihm rütteln und wollte sagen, hey, aufwachen, du musst irgendwas jetzt tun, du bist der Coach, du kannst das. Und der stand da wie so ein Boxtrainer in so einem Kampf, der immer irgendwie dieses Handtuch in der Hand hält und man so denkt, werf, werf, werf. Und er hat es nicht geschafft zu werfen. Ja, und also in dem Fall halt irgendwie einen Impuls zu setzen, der noch mal was gemacht hätte. Ich sage immer wieder, damit die Düsseldorfer, die diese Folge hören, nicht auch direkt wieder durchgetriggert werden, aber frühere Trainer wären wahrscheinlich irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, nackig über den Platz gerannt oder hätten sonst was gemacht oder hätten da irgendwie werden umgekippt am Spielfeldrand. Ich weiß es nicht. Irgendwas gemacht, um irgendwie diesen Spielfluss der Bochumer zu brechen. Und er stand halt eben einfach da und hat nichts gemacht. Und das ist auch zu erkennen gewesen, so in ein, zwei anderen dieser Top-Spiele, wo es auf so einer letzten Ebene, wo es dann nur noch um so Feinheiten geht, wo man halt eben einfach sieht, da braucht er noch was als Trainer. Da ist er noch nicht hundertprozentig angekommen, aber man hat so ein bisschen auch den Eindruck, dass er das genießt, in Düsseldorf auf diesem schon doch gehobenen Niveau trainieren zu dürfen, auch lernen zu dürfen weiterhin, auch von seinem Umfeld, mit einem Klaus-Alaus und wer auch immer da noch so rumspringt, auch von denen und von deren Erfahrung partizipieren zu können, sich abzuschauen, wo man manchmal auch so eine, ja, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht noch eine kleine Schweinerei einbauen kann, um seinem Ziel ein Stück weit näher zu kommen, ohne das jetzt boß abformulieren zu wollen. Und das sind halt so Punkte, wo ich glaube, deswegen habe ich gesagt, so Trainer in Ausbildung, was natürlich nicht despektierlich klingen soll, ist da schon natürlich sehr gestanden. Aber wenn wir jetzt am Ende über diese dreieinhalb Prozent noch reden, die dann nach ganz oben fehlen, die er eben noch reinholen kann und muss.
Aber damit hast du ja den Blick auch schon ein bisschen geweitet, auch weg von rein sportlichen Aspekten. Wo steht denn Fortuna Düsseldorf als Verein mit all seiner Geschichte, aber auch mit den neuen Wegen, die man ja geht? Stichwort Fortuna für alle zum Beispiel. Was ist da die aktuelle Entwicklung?
Also ich glaube, Fortuna geht es genauso wie nicht unbedingt allen 18 Zweitligisten, aber ich würde schon behaupten, der Mehrheit der Zweitligisten, das ist alles sehr am Limit gebaut. Das bedeutet, der Etat ist da, aber insgesamt der Fußball merkt man gerade, bewegt sich, ist irgendwie in einem Wandel, es geht nicht mehr alles so leicht, wie es mal war. Die Sponsoren stehen nicht ultimativ Schlange. Die Schulden bzw. die Verbindlichkeiten sind einfach vorhanden. Das ist so sehr oft so von der Hand in den Mund. Das ist alles sehr gefällig. Es sieht auch in Düsseldorf dann vielleicht immer noch mal so ein bisschen glamouröser aus als an anderen Standorten, aber das Ganze ist schon arg am Limit, wie gesagt. Und da ist jetzt nicht ein Riesenpuffer. Da ist auch jetzt nicht durch die ganzen Verkäufe, die es im Sommer gab oder die es letztendlich schon seit zwei Jahren gab, wo sehr viel Transferüberschuss erzielt wurde, ist nicht eine Situation geschaffen worden, wo man sich beruhigt zurücklehnen kann und sagen kann, hey, Klaus Ahlers als Sportvorstand und Christian Weber als Sportdirektor, die konnten jetzt sozusagen den XXL-Einkaufscorp sich schnappen und da jetzt losrennen, sondern man muss da mit sehr genauem Blick über den Transfermarkt gehen, weil eben halt die Gelder nicht so im Überfluss da sind. Nochmal, das ist nichts, was Düsseldorf exklusiv ist. Viele Zeichen zeigen in die richtige Richtung. Also der Heimsschnitt ist super gut. Die Zahlen gehen immer weiter nach oben. Also wenn man das vergleicht noch vor Jahren bei 25.000, letztes Jahr waren es irgendwie über 40.000 in der Saison. Das sind sicherlich vielversprechende Signale. Man muss halt eben auch nüchtern sagen, dass Fortuna für alle eine schöne Vision war und auch nach wie vor ist. Es aber bisher noch nicht in dem Maße gelungen ist, sagen wir mal, diese XXL-Sponsoren, neben dem Hauptsponsor Tagobank, jetzt noch davon zu überzeugen, von diesem Weg. Sodass natürlich immer irgendwie so gefühlt die, die, sagen wir mal, wie soll ich das ausdrücken, die Frage über allem steht, ist es in dieser Form, was das Geschäftsmodell angeht, Mitgliederverein etc., ein weiter gangbarer Weg oder muss man sich auch anderen Möglichkeiten öffnen? Das ist in Düsseldorf eine sehr klar zu beantwortende Frage. Da will man ja und auch keinen Funken von dieser, Mitgliederstruktur von Weichen, aber man spürt halt so ein bisschen im Hintergrund, so hinter den Kulissen, dass das natürlich immer so die beiden Dinge sind, die da so nebeneinander gestellt werden, wo ein bisschen suggeriert wird, naja, wenn wir könnten, wie wir wollten, dann wäre dies, das und so noch möglich.
Also Investoreneinstieg oder was meinst du dann quasi?
Beispielsweise, ja, dass man halt eben sagt, man würde diesen Weg wählen. So ist es einfach so, alles ist unfassbar auf Kante genäht. Es gibt noch ein paar offene Fragezeichen, Corona-Hilfen, die möglicherweise in Millionenhöhe zurückgezahlt werden müssen. Da sind noch ein paar offene Punkte, hier ist noch was, was man verbucht. Also das ist alles, wie soll ich ausdrücken, also sagen wir mal so, manche Kosten werden über so viele Jahre gestrickt, so dass man den Eindruck hat, wenn jetzt jemand zwingend zu Mediamarkt geht, oder zu einem anderen Elektrohändler und muss sich eine Playstation unbedingt kaufen und die auf Raten kaufen für irgendwie so und so viele Jahre, muss man vielleicht überlegen, ob es so eine sinnvolle Anschaffung ist in dem Moment oder ob man vielleicht dann lieber auf andere Dinge setzt. Und ich habe manchmal so den Eindruck, das Gesamtgeschäftsmodell Fußball geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung, dass man da nochmal arg drüber nachdenken muss, was es da für Ideen gesamtheitlich gibt, die nicht nur Fortuna Düsseldorf beantworten kann, sondern die der Fußball insgesamt beantworten muss, weil sie TV-Gelder, die nicht mehr so gesichert sind und auch nicht mehr in dieser Höhe so unbedingt fließen, spielen halt eine unfassbar große Rolle, wenn die nur in einem gewissen Rahmen einbrechen, wird das schon für viele Clubs zu einem vielleicht sogar existenziellen Problem. Und dem muss man sich ja einfach offen stellen, wie man dem entgegnen will.
Aber das heißt, dieser Versuch letztlich ja auch davon, so eine Art befreiungsschlag zu starten, indem man sagt, wir bieten im Idealfall unsere Tickets kostenlos an, haben damit immer ein volles Stadion und refinanzieren das eben durch die höhere Reichweite, die damit unsere Sponsoren haben, die damit auch dann mehr Geld dafür an uns bezahlen. Also dieser mögliche befreiungsschlag aus der totalen Abhängigkeit von den TV-Erlösen, der scheint jetzt– also das ist natürlich ein vorsichtiges Zwischenfazit, weil wir haben erst eine Saison gesehen, aber es klingt jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so optimistisch, was du da erzählst, dass das gelingt.
Naja, es ist halt eben auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr, wenn, dann langwieriger Prozess, bis man am Ende dann halt eben auf diese 17 Spiele kommt, die ja von der Utopie herausgegeben wurden, dass man sagt, alle Heimspiele sollen künftig kostenfrei angeboten werden oder nach einem Schlüssel, dass man das dann dementsprechend verteilt. Ich glaube einfach, dass es dazu ja dann doch schon noch nach einem größeren Umbruch bräuchte, weil der ist ja jetzt einfach so nicht in Sicht. Man hat jetzt sicherlich den Markt weiter geöffnet, dadurch, dass man halt eben weitere Spiele dazugenommen hat für diese Saison. Aber es fehlt einfach so an Unterstützung in der Breite. Da kommt immer wieder was und das sind sehr vielversprechende Signale auch. Aber so dieser ganz große Impuls, der ist davon bisher nicht gekommen. Das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran, muss man auch immer wieder ein bisschen vielleicht erklären, sagen. Natürlich viele Sponsoren haben mit Düsseldorf in den letzten 20, 25 Jahren auch sehr ambivalente Erfahrungen gemacht. Also dieser Verein, der war ja jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht so grundsolide geführt wie jetzt. Wir haben jetzt einen Vorstand, der geht in die Geschichtsbücher ein, weil er jetzt über drei Jahre in dieser Zusammensetzung dann im Amt sein wird. Also das ist unglaublich, ein Trainer, der jetzt schon zweieinhalb Jahre da ist. Also das, ich weiß nicht, andere mögen in Statistiken gewiefter sein, kann man ja alles schnell nachgucken. Das gab es aber schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr. Und wenn du halt eben beispielsweise im Sponsoring jede Saison wieder einen neuen Ansprechpartner hast, der dir neue Visionen erzählt und irgendwie neue Dinge erzählt, wie es dann größer, besser, toller wird, dann ist ja auch klar, dass es auf dem Sponsorenmarkt, glaube ich, für Fortuna Düsseldorf dann auch so eine gewisse Vorbehalte noch gab oder gibt. Und jetzt geht es halt um die Zeit, dass man, ich glaube, mit Alex Jobes grundsätzlich jemanden da am Werke hat, der da für verschiedene Dinge steht, der jetzt auch eine Kontinuität wieder reingebracht hat. Und da gilt es jetzt natürlich, ein Stück weit auch Geduld zu bewahren, um dann halt eben den einen oder anderen Sponsor auch durch vielleicht jetzt sportliche Höhenflüge davon zu überzeugen, dann da doch reinzukommen und Fortuna wieder als so sexy zu empfinden, wie es vielleicht mal war.
Wobei ich da, wenn ich mich kurz einschalten darf, ich finde es immer, beim 1. FC Nürnberg klingt es sehr, sehr ähnlich. Und ich finde es immer lustig, wenn dann die Gedanken vor allem darum gehen, wie man mehr Geld rein kriegt in den Verein. Klar, es gibt Vereine oder Unternehmen inzwischen in der ersten Liga, denen Geld vollkommen wurscht ist. Das Problem ist aber halt auch, dass in Vereinen wie unter anderem, im 1. FC Nürnberg mit dem Geld, das man hat und das ist auch nicht so wenig, einfach vollkommen beschissen umgegangen wird über Jahre und Jahrzehnte hinweg. Und ich glaube, das ist erst einmal das größere Problem, dass man an den Strukturen innerhalb dieser Vereine was ändern muss, die sich immer noch modernem Scouting verwehren, die absolut so regiert werden, wie es in den 80ern vielleicht auch schon immer cool war. Und das ist, glaube ich, eher das größere Problem, als dass man versucht, irgendwie noch mehr Kohle reinzuholen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein wirklich völlig berechtigter Punkt. Da kann ich nur zu 1000 Prozent zustimmen. Das ist sicherlich auch etwas, was wir immer wieder angemerkt haben, wenn man sich anschaut, dass die Personalkosten von Saison zu Saison, also außerhalb des Budgets für den Profisport, immer weiter steigen. Also man da noch einen Direktor posten hat, den noch irgendwie braucht, um das und das zu beobachten oder zu kontrollen. Und was weiß ich alles, also dass so ein Riesen-Wasserkopf, der da vor sich hergetragen wird, ist wirklich absolut berechtigt der Punkt. Und nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich, aber das rein, was jetzt, ich kann jetzt für Düsseldorf vor allen Dingen nur sprechen, infrastrukturell da noch zu tun ist, einfach das Geld doch dann dringend gebraucht würde, weil Stichwort professionelle Trainingsbedingungen in Düsseldorf gibt es Container, wo die Trainer drin hausen, um da ihre Vorbereitung zu machen. Also muss weiß Gott jetzt nichts Schlimmes sein. Also es gibt schlimmere Schicksale, als dieses Container zu hausen. Aber ich will nur damit sagen, es ist jetzt weit weg von Glamour. Das sind halt irgendwie übereinander gestapelte Container, wo man da irgendwie da hochkrackseln muss, um dann da irgendwie vom Trainer sich die Deviten lesen zu lassen. Kann ja auch was durchaus Heilsames sein. Aber insgesamt– weiß ich nicht– sind das halt Investitionen. Es gab halt eben die Idee, beispielsweise ein Multifunktionsgebäude an der Arena zu bauen. Das wurde dann aber– auch so ein Klassiker– jetzt über fast schon Jahre zerredet zwischen Politik, Investoren, X, Y, Z. Und am Ende steht man jetzt halt eben einfach da und hat einen Platz im Winter, der überhaupt bespielbar wäre, was Training angeht. Und ansonsten muss man dann irgendwie gucken, wie man sich behilft. Und das sind so viele kleine Mosaiksteine. Das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum platzt aus allen Nähten. Man muss für die Frauenmannschaft gucken, wo man überhaupt noch irgendwie Slots findet. Also alles richtig. Man muss mit dem Geld vernünftig haushalten. Da ist auch ganz viel Schindluder, 100%ig in der Vergangenheit und vielleicht auch Gegenwart getrieben worden. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es auch viele Projekte, die so ein Verein hat. Also das heißt, ich glaube, zu wenig Geld kann man auch irgendwie nicht haben. Und es ist letztendlich, ja, es ist so ein Pulverfassende, wenn man vor allen Dingen da mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht, dann japst man natürlich umso mehr nach dem Geld. Wenn es dann oben gut läuft, gerade klopfen sich alle auf die Schultern und sagen, ah, geht doch, da haben wir dann doch irgendwie wieder gut hingekriegt. Aber noch mal aus meiner Sicht tritt auf der Rasierklinge, weil wenn der ein oder andere Verkauf in den letzten Monaten nicht getätigt worden wäre, also dass wir beispielsweise, dass Düsseldorf, um genauer zu sein, jetzt auf den letzten Drücker AOTanaka noch losgeworden ist und dann auch noch für so eine unfassbar große Summe von dreieinhalb Millionen plus Boni, das liegt im Prinzip daran, dass am Ende sich wirklich zwei Blöde getroffen haben. Der eine, der jetzt über zwei Jahre versucht hat, AOTanaka loszuwehren und der andere, der jetzt auf den letzten Drücker dann doch noch jemanden brauchte, Tanaka dann in die 2. Englische Liga gegangen, obwohl er irgendwie von sonst was die ganze Zeit geträumt und auch geredet hat. Und dann sind am Ende dreieinhalb Millionen plötzlich noch in die Kasse gespült worden. Man stelle sich vor, die wären dann nicht gekommen. Was hätte man dann für Probleme möglicherweise gehabt? Also ist auch immer beim Fußball ein bisschen mit Glück verbunden und nicht unbedingt unfassbar viel im Können.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist der Kontext auch immer entscheidend. Also, ihr habt natürlich beide Recht, dass gerade die Ausgabenseite ein Problem ist im Fußball. Auf der anderen Seite, eine Einnahmenssteigung musst du schon erziehen, weil du musst die Zinsen auf deine Verbindlichkeiten reinholen und die Inflation mit reinrechnen. Also ein gewisses Wachstum muss es geben. So funktioniert unsere Wirtschaft. Und auf der anderen Seite reden wir hier aber von zwei Vereinen. Ich erkläre gleich, warum ich da den 1. FC Nürnberg mit reinnehme, die am oberen Ende der Nahrungskette in der 2. Liga stehen. Also von den Zahlen her ist man im deutschen Profifußball. Ich beziehe mich jetzt auf die Zahlen von 22, 23. Das sind die letzten, die vorliegen von der DFL. Da ist man irgendwo in den 20ern. Also Platz 22 ist die Fortuna da. Das heißt eben hinter den Top 18, wobei nicht alle davon der ersten Liga spielen, ist man da relativ nah dran. Also noch im oberen Segment. Das zeigt ja schon, wenn selbst da schon die Ausgabenkultur so ist, dass es sehr, sehr eng und auf Kante genäht ist. Dann kann man sich vorstellen, was bei Vereinen noch weiter hinten der Fall ist. Und jetzt kommt aber die eigentliche Pointe, weil gefühlt spielt gerade Fortuna Düsseldorf in einer anderen Liga, auch was so die Konzepte angeht, die Schritte, die man geht, Fortuna für alle und so weiter und so fort, als der erste FC Nürnberg. Aber wirtschaftlich sind das im Grunde– alle Fans verzeihen mir, kurz weghören– dieselben Vereine. Der Klub hatte laut DFL-Zahlen 26 Millionen Euro Personalaufwand bei 50 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis. Fortuna Düsseldorf 26 Millionen Euro Personalaufwand bei 51 Millionen Euro Rohergebnis. Also Fadi, warum ist der Klub nicht wie Fortuna Düsseldorf?
Klingt erst mal nach einer potenziellen fanfreundschaft, aber die will ich hier nicht ausrufen. Warum ist der Klub nicht wie Fortuna Düsseldorf? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt schon wieder Dieter Hecking erwähnen soll. Das ist hier Geschichte in Nürnberg, deshalb wahrscheinlich nicht. Weil es in den letzten Jahren einfach zu viele Fehler gab in diesem Verein. Was die Besetzung des Postens des Sportvorstands betraf, beginnend mit dem Sommer nach dem Abstieg aus der ersten Liga 2.19, als Robert Palikutche übernommen hat, übernahm Dieter Hecking nach dem Beinahe-Abstieg in die dritte Liga. Das schien so eine Zeit lang ein bisschen gut zu gehen mit dem Trainer Robert Klaus, aber der wurde dann in der zweiten oder dritten halbernsen Krise entlassen und es kamen wieder andere Trainer. Und jetzt im Sommer der komplette Umbruch mit Sportvorstand weg, Trainer weg, Pressesprecher weg, 15 Spieler weg, weil Cani vorhin die Kontinuität betont hat, die so wichtig ist in dieser Liga. Der erste FC Nürnberg ist das Gegenbeispiel.
Irgendwann muss die Kontinuität ja auch starten können, Fadi. So musst du sehen. Aber bevor wir da auf der Sportliche kommen, würde mich interessieren, wenn du jetzt das wirst, was Cani zur infrastruktur bei Fortuna Düsseldorf erzählt hat, ist das vergleichbar mit dem Club oder sieht es da anders auf?
Die infrastruktur in Nürnberg ist eigentlich okay. Also es gibt ausreichend Trainingsplätze, auch mit Rasenheizungen, auf die die Mannschaft im Winter ausweichen kann. Es gibt ein Funktionsgebäude ohne Containerdorf, in dem die Trainer und auch die Spieler und sogar noch ein bisschen die Geschäftsstelle Platz finden und so was. Also das ist eigentlich okay. Hat damals noch Martin Baader, der Sportvorstand, der hier in Nürnberg auch nicht in bester Erinnerung, so im Nachhinein geblieben ist, bauen lassen. Ja, also deshalb infrastruktur ist eigentlich okay. Es wurde die Vermarktung in die eigene Hand genommen. Ob das jetzt, also man hat sich bei Sport5, glaube ich, heißen sie gerade, rausgekauft und hat so eine eigene Vermarktungsgesellschaft aufgebaut, die im Moment vor allem dafür berühmt ist, dass sie Klein- und Kleinsponsoren an Land holt. Aber infrastrukturell ist es eigentlich okay, bis darauf, dass sich in Nürnberg sehr viele Menschen ein neues Stadion wünschen, weil sie sagen, das ist halt einfach ein Wettbewerbsnachteil. Da sind die Planungen inzwischen relativ weit fortgeschritten. Man muss sich allerdings sehr viele Investoren und die Stadt mit reinholen, um das Ganze finanzieren zu können. Aber das ist im Moment so ein bisschen, ich bin skeptisch, ob es je wirklich gebaut oder umgebaut wird. Aber da sind im Moment alle einigermaßen hoffnungsrot, dass dann auch die Einnahmeseite wieder viel besser ist, wenn du mehr Logen und Wippplätze und sonst was verkaufen kannst. Das ist im Moment das große Ding in Nürnberg.
Also es ist jetzt ein wild guess, aber der DFB bewirbt sich ja um die Frauen-Europameisterschaft 2029. Es braucht ja immer wieder so einen Anlass, auf den man so einen Stadion hin renoviert, und dann fließen die öffentlichen Gelder, sitzen dann ein bisschen lockerer. Vielleicht kann da ja der Club mal mit reinsteigen.
Zumal in Nürnberg der Frauenfußball tatsächlich das krasse Gegenbeispiel ist. Die sind zwar gerade aus der ersten Liga abgestiegen werden, aber dieses Jahr auch dank dreier Aufstiegsplätze jetzt aus der zweiten Liga mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wieder aufsteigen. Und da ist es eben so, die haben auch keine Kohle, aber die haben moderne Strukturen, auch wenn es wirklich eine sehr kleine Abteilung ist. Aber da wird richtig gut gearbeitet mit Ossmann Cankajer, mit dem Trainer Thomas Ostendorp und so. Und es werden immer wieder Spielerinnen und auch der Trainer nach einer Spielidee verpflichtet. All so Dinge, die man bei den Männern in Nürnberg überhaupt nicht sieht. Also der Frauenfußball ist das schönere Thema in Nürnberg, schon seit mindestens eineinhalb Jahren.
Absolut. Das haben wir ja auch im Rasenfunk sehr gerne begleitet. Und da freue ich mich auch drauf. Sollte das wirklich so kommen, dass das im nächsten Jahr dann auch wieder so sein wird. Aber dann erklär mir doch mal, warum war dieser sportliche Kahlschlag ja fast schon notwendig? Du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Im Grunde Führungspersonal ausgetauscht und Kader einmal durchgewischt.
Ja, also nach zwei Jahren unterm Sportvorstand Dieter Hecking, die letzten zwei Jahren zweimal Klassenverbleib in der 2. Liga, erst relativ spät am letzten und ich weiß nicht, letzte Saison, was auch irgendwie drei, vier Spieltage vor dem Ende klar gemacht und so was. Und dann ein, zwei öffentliche Auftritte von Dieter Hecking, die so semi-optimal gelaufen sind, wo es unter anderem um Demonstrationen ging, die er als gegen rechts, die er als Folklore bezeichnet hat und so was. Hat sich im Aufsichtsrat dann doch irgendwann die Erkenntnis durchgesetzt, dass das vielleicht nicht die allerbeste Idee ist, mit ihm weiterzumachen. Und es kam dann Joti Haccialexiu vom Deutschen Fußballbund, bei dem er 20 Jahre gearbeitet hat. Und der hat dann aufgrund einer Datenanalyse festgestellt, dass die letzte Saison unter Christian Vell auch in den Phasen, in denen in Nürnberg alle dachten, endlich wird da wieder Fußball gespielt und schöner Fußball gespielt, dass die nicht so ganz super war. Und hat deshalb erst Vell nach Berlin gehen lassen, als der den Wunsch geäußert hat, ohne große Gefühlsregung. Und hat das ähnlich dann bei den Spielern aus der letzten Saison gehalten. Also da durfte nach der Saison wirklich jeder, der sich in Nürnberg nicht mehr wohlgefühlt hat, gehen und mussten ein paar andere gehen. Und deshalb kommt man dann halt zu diesem Umbruch mit 15 neuen und einem neuen Trainer. Mit Miroslav Klose.
Mit Miroslav Klose, der ja dann logischerweise auch Wunschtrainer sein dürfte. Oder? Ich bin extra mit der Stimme hochgegangen, am Schluss, um die Tür zu öffnen.
Ich bin mir nicht so 100% sicher, ob es aufs Wunschtrainer war. Ich glaube, es war am Ende derjenige, der unbedingt nach Nürnberg wollte von den Kandidaten, die es gab. Dann hat, glaube ich, HC Alexio darauf vertraut, die Strahlkraft eines Weltmeisters kann die Situation hier in Nürnberg, die ja doch immer sehr aufgeregt ist, einigermaßen beruhigen. So ist es tatsächlich auch. Im Umfeld wurde Klose erst mal als Sensationsverpflichtung wahrgenommen, weil eben ein Weltmeister von 2014 kommt. Und es gab bei seiner Verpflichtung schon Stimmen, die gesagt haben, er ist eben als Spieler-Weltmeister geworden und nicht als Trainer. Und die müssen sich bislang noch nicht widerlegt fühlen.
Ich finde, aus der Distanz, wenn ich meinen Eindruck über ihn teilen darf, ist einfach immer alles so schrecklich unbeholfen. Also das ist super sympathisch irgendwie. Man kann das auch als authentisch bezeichnen. Aber man merkt einfach, dass er so in diesem System, was da halt eben einfach um ihn herum ist, das kann man jetzt ja nicht sich wegdenken, einfach das Ganze so sehr schnell geht, sage ich mal. Da kommen halt Fragen, die muss er dann in irgendeiner Weise verarbeiten und muss darauf wie auch immer Antworten finden. Ich fand auch so diesen Umgang, als es da diese Situation gab, wo seinem Spieler die Sicherungen durchgegangen sind, wo man natürlich einerseits sagt, so ist dann eben der Miroclose, Fairplay und so weiter und so fort. Aber man hatte nicht so das Gefühl, das sieht man öfters bei Trainern, die dann so über einer Mannschaft stehen und nicht wirklich so in dieser Mannschaft schon so organisch drin sind. Und mit allem, was ich eben schon mal so zart habe versucht zu sagen, das muss man auch nicht gut heißen. Ich sage nur einfach, dass das so ein bisschen Teil natürlich dieser Branche ist. Mit so, ja, sagen wir mal vorsichtig ausgedrückt, so kleinen Schlawiner-Methoden, dann versuchen auch wirklich das Maximum für ihren Verein dann rauszuholen.
Ja, das ist er tatsächlich überhaupt nicht. Also es ist einer ungelogen, einer der ehrlichsten und am ehrlich freundlichsten Menschen, die ich in diesem Geschäft habe kennenlernen dürfen bislang. Aber ob er wirklich ein guter Trainer ist, daran habe ich sehr, sehr große Zweifel.
Und ganz kurz bei dem Spieler, da ging es um den Jubel beim Siegtreffer in Ulm. War das die Geschichte vor den gegnerischen Fans oder meintest du was anderes, Gianni?
Ich glaube die rote Karte danach.
Genau, ich meinte diese rote Karte und seinen Umgang damit, die ja faktisch gesehen– um mich nicht falsch zu verstehen, das war total korrekt und das war auch selten dämlich von dem Spieler– nur dieser Umgang damit, der ist halt eben einfach, fand ich jetzt persönlich, ein bisschen schwierig und weiß halt, wie auch Mannschaften manchmal auf sowas reagieren. Das kann dann auch schnell nach hinten losgehen, wenn du dann so das Gefühl hast, dein Trainer ist so der Fährste von allen, dann ist das immer was, was natürlich auch bei einem Team ankommt und das kann eine Signalwirkung haben, klar. Einerseits ist auch ein tolles Zeichen gewesen. Wie gesagt, ich möchte da nicht missverstanden werden, aber die Erfahrung zeigt, dass so das ein oder andere Team mit so Signalen auch Probleme hat.
Okay, und das war eben, also das war diese Rempler, da gab es Rot und Miro Klose.
Genau, diese Eishockey-Szene.
Ja, okay, genau. Der Sport hat verwechselt. Jetzt habe ich es endlich. Okay, halbwegs vor Augen.
Ja, und da ist er halt direkt auf den Platz gerannt. Und da sind ja auch ein paar Sachen direkt ohne er gegangen, die einfach dann manchmal fürs Innenleben Schwierigkeiten mit sich bringen können.
Das meinte ich mit dieser Ehrlichkeit auch. Also es ist wirklich keiner, der dir irgendwie Bullshit erzählt. Aber ja, es ist schwierig. Schwierig. Er ist auch einer, der ein sehr ruhiger Trainer ist, was ja vollkommen okay ist. Also man sieht ihn oft sehr lange nicht an der Seitenlinie, sondern er sitzt halt auf seiner Bank. Ich möchte jetzt nicht in dieses Körpersprachen-Messun-Ösil-Dings reinkommen und sowas, aber was dann natürlich von einem Teil des Publikums auch bemerkt wird, was vielleicht auch von einem Teil der Mannschaft bewirkt wird, das kam dann so ein bisschen in die Diskussionen in Nürnberg, Klose zu ruhig und sowas. Jetzt hatten wir ihn dann am Samstag gegen die Hertha plötzlich ständig an der Seitenlinie hin und her laufen sehen, was dann vielleicht auch nicht so ganz authentisch wirkt und drüber kommt. Also dann lieber sitzen bleiben.
Du hast manchmal ein bisschen in Deutschland und auch mit dem Trainer seinem Fußball das Problem, dass du, wenn man sich Miro Klose anschaut, kommt man doch relativ schnell. Wenn man den jetzt in so einem Bewerbungsverfahren sich anschaut, kommt man eigentlich dazu, dass dem so und so viele Skills für den Chef-Trainer einfach zum Zeitpunkt X noch fehlen. Dann würde man beispielsweise beim American Football sagen, vielleicht ist er erstmal ein guter Spezial-Coach und müsste da irgendwie versuchen, sich so lange hoch zu arbeiten, bis er dann halt eben auch sicher darin ist im Umgang, in der Außendarstellung, in verschiedenen anderen Dingen, auch auf höchster Ebene halt. Es gibt Trainer, die sind ja quasi mit so einem Trainerschein geboren und da kann man sagen, ob die jetzt 26 sind oder 32, eigentlich ziemlich wurscht. Also die haben das irgendwie so. Bei Miru Klose ist tatsächlich natürlich so diese große Aura, wenn man sie dann als große Aura empfindet. Also ich habe jetzt persönlich nicht so den Eindruck, dass da jetzt dieser Weltmeister-Schimmer sich da immer so vor ihm herwalzt. Aber da hat man natürlich vor allen Dingen das und immer so diese Idee, kriegen wir auch so einen Weltmeister-Spieler zu einem Weltmeister-Trainer. Und da zeigt sich ja einfach, warum es so unfassbar wichtig sein kann, nicht muss. Man sieht es, wie eingangs gesagt, an verschiedenen Beispielen, dass man ja auch verschiedene Evolutionsschritte überspringen kann als Trainer. Aber warum das halt eben dann doch sinnvoll ist, bei dem einen oder anderen, dass man da schon ruhig an die Sache rangeht und auch wirklich Lehrjahre da reinlegt. Und ja, 2. Liga, gerade bei so einem Club wie Nürnberg, da gibt es halt schon viele Herausforderungen. Und die allerwenigsten haben klassisch mit dem Trainerjob zu tun. Ich finde immer erst so jemand, ich glaube, wenn ich junger Spieler wäre, 6er im Lotto, Miro Klose irgendwie in meiner Nähe zu haben. Hundertprozentig. Absoluter Topmann für sowas. Und dann gibt es dann wieder andere Aufgaben, die du so brauchst in diesem Business, wo ich sage, naja, da ist dann definitiv wahrscheinlich noch Luft nach oben.
Ja, da gibt es tatsächlich einige. Ich glaube, Miro Klose will unbedingt Profi, Trainer sein. Und ich habe große Zweifel, ob er es dann nach seiner Zeit in Nürnberg auch noch sein wird.
Aber warum, Fadi? Also wir haben jetzt viel über Außenwirkungen und so weiter gesprochen, Verhalten an der Seitenlinie. Wir können ja auch, wenn du magst, mal gerne ein bisschen mehr auf die Spiele gucken, die bisher unter ihm geleitet wurden. Also was sind quasi so die sportlichen Zweifel, die du hast?
Es gab bislang sechs Ligaspiele, ein Pokalspiel und es gab keine einzige Partie davon, in der der Klub seinem Gegner überlegen war. Es waren unter anderem der Sieg gegen Schalke, die erste Halbzeit komplett unterlegen. Schalke führt 1-0, dann gibt es einen absolut lächerlichen Platzverweis für Schalke und das nutzt der Klub dann gut. Es war das Spiel in Ulm. Der Sieg in Ulm war das einzige Spiel, in dem der 1. FC Nürnberg einen besseren XG-Wert hatte, als der Gegner bislang, was auch einigermaßen bezeichnend ist. Also es fehlt vollkommen eine Spielidee. Miroslav Klose und JK. Alexiou haben vor der Saison, oder vor allem hat es der Sportvorstand gesagt, dass er einen Trainer gesucht hat, der so in etwa die fielische Spielphilosophie fortsetzen will. Davon ist absolut gar nichts zu sehen. Miroslav Klose betont seit Amtsantritt die Intensität. Der 1. FC Nürnberg ist eine Mannschaft, die in dieser Saison an Intensität komplett fehlt. Die Spielidee ist im Moment meist ein langer Ball auf Lukas Schleimer, der eigentlich kein Mittelstürmer ist. Dann ist der Ball auch wieder weg. Es wirkt nicht so, als würde sich irgendetwas bessern. Diese sieben Punkte, die der 1. FC Nürnberg bislang gesammelt hat, sind wirklich einfach nur glücklich zustande gekommen. Das ist in so einer Phase der Saison ein bisschen schwierig, wenn du anders als der 1. FC Köln bist. Die großartigen Fußballspieler arbeiten sich Chancen um Chance heraus. Aber Tim Lempel, als Angreifer, der gerne die schönsten Dinge und solche Möglichkeiten hat, erarbeitet sich der 1. FC Nürnberg gar nicht. Die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten Ballaktionen im gegnerischen strafraum– 106 waren das bislang in den Zweitligaspielen. Und selbst Jan Regensburg auf Platz 17 hat 117 Ballaktionen im gegnerischen strafraum. Der Klub hat die wenigsten Schüsse, die wenigsten Pässe ins Angriffstrittel. Und die sind dann auch noch schlecht. Also es ist keinerlei Idee zu erkennen bislang, wie die Fußball spielen wollen.
Aber andererseits, es hat…
Ja, da bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Ein weiser Mann hat gesagt, mit den Punkten, da haben sie sich Zeit erkauft. Es ist noch gar nicht so lange her, dass das jemand gesagt hat. Und ein bisschen ist es da beim Klub auch so. Klar, es sind sieben Punkte nach sechs Spielen nicht perfekt, aber immerhin sind es sieben Punkte. Und gerade wenn man das eben anerkennt, was du sagst, dass der Klub bisher eigentlich nie so wirklich überlegen war, muss man ja auch dankbar sein für jeden Dreier, der darunter gefallen ist. Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber auch erst sechs Spiele, plus eben diesen krassen Umbruch auch im Kader. Also müsste man da jetzt nicht vielleicht auch mal sagen, Augen zu und jetzt mal der sportlichen Leitung erstmal vertrauen. Weil wenn Joti Catialexo Miroslav Klose haben wollte oder von ihm überzeugt ist– und da habe ich jetzt nichts anderes gehört, korrigier mich bitte ansonsten gerne– dann muss man sagen, ja gut, also mindestens eine Halbserie, so wie Gianni eigentlich, nur halt quasi aus der anderen Haltung heraus. Gianni sagt, für mich zählt es erst ab Weihnachten. Bis dahin bin ich mal ganz vorsichtig erstmal. Natürlich aus der Luxushaltung heraus aktueller Tabellenführer. Aber im Grunde müsste man doch das als Minimum auch Klose und Catialexo und dem ganzen Unfeld geben.
Ja, ja. Offiziell ist es auch noch so, dass der Sportvorstand keine Trainer-Diskussion beginnen will, die natürlich längst begonnen hat in Nürnberg. Und es ist halt auch aus Erfahrung so, dass sich irgendwann die Punktausbeute eher den Leistungen anpasst als umgekehrt. Und es war bisher wirklich viel zu wenig. Und es gibt auch keine wirkliche Reaktion, auch während der Spiele auf irgendwelche Probleme, die sich da auftun, kommt da von der Trainerbank relativ wenig. Und zum großen Umbruch, den gab es tatsächlich. Allerdings gegen die Hertha, am Samstag waren sieben Spieler in der Startelf, die in der vergangenen Saison schon beim 1. FC Nürnberg angestellt waren. Also da relativiert sich die ganze Sache dann auch wieder. Weil die müssten einander eigentlich kennen. Ich glaube wirklich, ich würde gerne positive Dinge sagen, aber nicht, dass dieses Projekt Zukunft hat über die nächste Länderspielpause hinaus.
Muss ich kurz überlegen, Mitte Oktober ist das, das ist schon relativ bald.
Ja, ich glaube zwei Spiele sind es jetzt noch, oder? Und dann ist Länderspielpause. Also es kommt jetzt das Auswärtsspiel in Hannover und dann Heimspiel gegen Münster. Es gibt Menschen im Verein, die auch da sehr inoffiziell sagen, dass man aus diesen beiden Spielen vielleicht vier Punkte holen sollte. Das sehe ich im Moment nicht so kommen.
Meine Erkenntnis ist auf jeden Fall schon nach diesem Rasenfunk, niemals Stress mit Fadi anfang.
Den wirst du nicht bekommen, es sei denn, du wirst Trainer des ersten FC Nürnberg oder Sportverstand.
Ja, und trotzdem finde ich es aber auch, also ich verstehe natürlich, was du sagst und meine Güte, warum habe ich den Club hier ausgewählt als Schwerpunkt, weil ich schon auch mitbekommen habe, das läuft gerade nicht so und die Sachen, die ich gesehen habe, waren jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich da auf Knien niedergegangen bin, ob der schönen Spielkunst des Clubs. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber halt auch so deprimierend, dass man keinerlei Zeit in diesem Geschäft bekommt und bei allen, also ich verstehe alles, was du sagst. Ich habe eigentlich auch keine Gegenargumente, außer das eine wäre es nicht irgendwie schön, wenn man einmal ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben könnte.
Mein Kollege Uli Dijkmaier hat tatsächlich am Sonntag auf NNDE einen Kommentar verfasst, in dem er mehr oder weniger sich das erste Mal in der Geschichte dieses Verlagshaus dafür entschuldigt, dass da möglicherweise demnächst ein Trainer rausfliegen könnte, weil alle Miroslav Klose die Zeit geben wollen würden, wenn nicht von Beginn an die Zweifel daran bestanden hätten, dass er in diesem Job vielleicht nicht der Richtige ist, was ja auch einfach mal sein kann.
Ich meine, wenn du mit Leuten im Alltag sprichst, das werdet ihr wahrscheinlich auch gemacht haben.
Exakt.
Interesse, aber Fadi?
Ja, bitte, Entschuldigung.
Mit Blick auf– ich habe gerade mal den Staff da aufgerufen von Nürnberg, um so ein bisschen zu gucken, wer eigentlich dahintersteht, und neben der Überraschung, dass es auch in Nürnberg ein Head of Performance gibt.
Auch ein sehr gutes Thema, wenn man auf die Laufleistungen und die intensiven Läufe dann blickt. Da wundert sich auch einige.
Da gibt es ja unterschiedliche Interpretationen, was dieser Head of Performance überhaupt so machen soll, aber ohne jetzt Jens Bauer und Rabih Pinola zu nahe treten zu wollen, stelle ich mir halt eben einfach die Frage, wenn man jetzt grundsätzlich nicht sagt, man will sich nicht verrennen in so einem Projekt, Miroclose, wenn man jetzt einfach merkt, warum auch immer, in Klammern, das hätte man natürlich dann ja auch schon vor seiner Anstellung irgendwie wissen können, wenn man ihn so ein bisschen beobachtet hätte bei seiner letzten Trainerstation, ob da nicht vielleicht noch so die letzte Notbremse wäre, zu sagen, da kommt noch ein bisschen Erfahrung in diesen Trainerstab rein, also dass man so jemanden holt, ich kann mich dran erinnern, Eine Fortuna hat das gemacht mit dem Manni Stewes, langjähriger Wegbegleiter von Lucien Favre bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Dass man halt sagt, man holt da noch jemanden dazu, der dieses Geschäft super, super, super gut kennt, der vielleicht Ruhe reinbringt, der dem Trainer auch einfach Aufgaben abnehmen kann, wo er sich aber hundertprozentig darauf verlassen kann, dass er dich, dass er sozusagen jetzt nur noch in so einem Lernmodus das und dies übernimmt und damit dann auch nicht so die Gefahr ist, dass er sich so verhaspelt. Also das fände ich jetzt persönlich, glaube ich. Und dann bin ich ja bei Max, weil ich halt sage, das ist ja gerade diese Krux in diesem Geschäft, dass man erstens so oft daneben liegt. Da muss man ja einfach die Frage stellen, woran liegt das? Warum sind so viele Personaleinscheidungen einfach falsch? Und zweitens, wieso gibt man dem Ganzen dann nicht Zeit, wenn man versucht, wenn man nicht jetzt grundsätzlich sagt, es geht einfach nicht. Das gibt es ja auch, dass man einfach merkt, man hat sich für jemand entschieden, funktioniert dann aber menschlich einfach dann doch nicht. Okay, dann muss es halt eine Trennung geben oder eine Entscheidung geben. Aber in dem Fall würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen, so aus der neumal klugen Sicht aus dem Rheinland heraus, das ist eine Leichttätel ja ganz gut, wenn man ihm Hilfe gibt.
Ja, die Diskussion gibt es in Nürnberg natürlich auch. Es gab ja 2009 war das, glaube ich, mit Michael Oening auch einen jungen, unerfahrenen Trainer, dem dann Peter Herrmann zur Seite gestellt wurde.
Der ewige Peter.
Genau, er wird auch derzeit wieder gefordert. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das so wichtig ist, dass du einen erfahrenen hast. Ich glaube einfach, wenn fachlich alles stimmt, dann können da auch vier 17-jährige Co-Trainer, Head of Performance und sonstige sein. Dann funktioniert es, wenn es fachlich und in der Ansprache an die Mannschaft und an die Öffentlichkeit funktioniert. Und all das sehe ich halt einfach im Moment in Nürnberg nicht. Das, ja, das ist…
Und welche Rolle spielt da denn der Kader, der ja nicht von Miroslav Klose zusammengestellt wurde? Also es ist ja nicht nur der Trainer.
Nee, Kader, da sind tatsächlich in Nürnberg immer noch, nachdem jetzt über drei, vier Jahre immer die Kader-Zusammenstellung kritisiert wurde, muss man nämlich auch noch immer ein Einschränkung dazu sagen, dass hier in den letzten Jahren selten mal Trainer kritisiert worden sind, wenn sie nicht Markus Weinziel hießen, sondern Robert Klaus und Christian Fjell haben in der Öffentlichkeit relativ viel Kredit bekommen. Und da hieß es immer, denen wurde der falsche Kader hingestellt, was ja glaube ich auch wirklich die coolere Variante ist, dass es nicht die Schuld des Trainers ist, sondern des Menschen, der die Mannschaft zusammenstellt. In dieser Saison glaube ich, dass das tatsächlich ein bisschen anders ist, dass die Mannschaft vielleicht sogar besser ist als die des Vorjahrs. Ich glaube, der Sportvorstand hat da, nachdem er dann auf seinen Posten berufen wurde, noch ein paar Transfers, die schon geplant waren, so hört man es zumindest auch nochmal abgesagt und nochmal neu, darum gebeten, ins Scouting zu gehen. Und ich betonte auch, dass in Nürnberg sich am Scouting, auch was Datenscouting betrifft, sehr viel ändern muss. Und dass er das vielleicht ein bisschen anders erwartet hätte, bei einem Fußball-Zweitligisten im Jahr 2024. Und ja, deshalb, die Mannschaft ist okay zusammengestellt. Also ich glaube nicht so, dass es Julian Justwahn gibt, der bewiesen hat, dass er ein überdurchschnittlicher, Entschuldigung, Zweitligaspieler sein kann. Also die Mannschaft müsste eigentlich besser Fußball spielen können. Als es derzeit tut.
Also Robin Knoche sicherlich noch ein bekannter Name für die Innenverteidigung. Danilo Zsoares, Florian Pick aus Heidenheim. Das sind jetzt nur ein paar der vielen Neuzugänge, aber ich wollte mal so ein paar Namen nennen, die vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen kennen.
Genau. Caspar Janda, bislang bester Spieler der Saison vom MSV Duisburg gekommen. Ein sehr talentierter Mittelfeldspieler, Stefanos Tsimas, der die rote Karte in Ulln gesehen hat. Ein griechischer Unnationalspieler, auch mit sehr guten Anlagen. Es ist schon ein bisschen Fantasie dabei, Robin Knoche. Suarez und Pikk, weil du die genannt hast, die sahen bislang in dieser Saison noch nicht so gut aus, obwohl sie so ein Teil der neuen Achse sind. Und was man dann in der Kaderzusammenstellung beim 1. FC Nürnberg seit Jahren oder seit einiger Zeit immer wieder erwähnen muss, ist, dass es keine wirkliche Konkurrenz für Florian Flick auf der 6. gibt. Und der jetzt schon ein paar Mal bewiesen hat, dass er im Spielaufbau vielleicht nicht der Pressing-Resistenteste ist. Also wenn man an dieser Kaderzusammenstellung was unbedingt kritisieren muss, dann ist es, dass auf der Position jetzt wiederholt nicht gehandelt wurde, um da neue Akzente setzen zu können.
Okay, also wenn ich dann aber jetzt mal versuche, ein Zwischenfazit zu ziehen, denn was anderes kann das ja nach sechs Spieltagen noch gar nicht sein, dann sehe ich Umbruch im Kader angegangen, aber da sind auf jeden Fall noch Themen offen. Umbruch auf der Trainerposition, aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach nicht zufriedenstellend erfüllt. Da wird vermutlich noch etwas passieren. Situation des Gesamtvereins. Stimmung nehme ich schon wieder als relativ gereizt wahr. Was wahrscheinlich mit den sportlichen Leistungen zusammenhängt, war aber– ich komme ja aus der Ecke– nie anders beim Klub.
Man muss wirklich die gesamte Stimmungslage jetzt unter dem Eindruck der vergangenen 24 Monate betrachten. Wie ich vorhin schon mal sagte, da hat sich sehr viel Frust angestaut. Unabhängig davon, die fachliche Bewertung von Miroslav Klose, das Arbeit bislang als Trainer, ist halt auch einfach unzureichend.
Aber das heißt, wir befinden uns quasi in einem Zwischenstadium. Im Grunde, weil wenn wir jetzt quasi uns die Tabelle angucken würden und einfach so täten, als wäre Dieter Hecking noch im Amt und als wäre noch Trainer XY da, dann wäre es ja genauso wie immer eigentlich beim Klub.
Ja.
Das heißt, wir haben quasi als Zwischenfazit, der Umbruch ist eingeleitet, es ist aber noch an keiner Stelle außerhalb quasi beim Kader und so weiter zu erkennen, dass sich schon etwas nach vorne bewegt hätte. Es hat sich nur viel verändert.
Genau. Und der Fußball ist schlechter geworden als zum Beispiel in der Anfangszeit von Christian Vell, der auch nicht sehr viel bessere Ergebnisse geliefert hat. Aber zu Beginn der vergangenen Saison war es eben, dass in Nürnberg die Menschen wieder gerne in Stadion gegangen sind, weil da so ein Ansatz einer Spielidee zu erkennen war. Jetzt im Moment noch nicht.
Im Moment noch nicht. Aber das kann sich erinnern. Fadi, ich bin sehr gespannt. Man kann es ja dann bei euch im KDEP Podcast hautnah verfolgen. Ich zähle jetzt schon die Spiele bis zur Länderspielpause runter. Interessantes Phänomen übrigens, dadurch, dass Miroslav Klose anders ist als viele Trainer, dadurch, dass er ehrlicher ist als viele andere Menschen, mit denen man im Fußball zu tun hat, kenne ich mit der einen Einschränkung, dass es manchmal schwierig ist, über ihn Geschichten zu schreiben, kenne ich aber ganz wenige Leute aus unserer Branche, die nicht irgendwie Miroslav Klose gönnen würden, Erfolg zu haben. Das ist ein sehr interessantes Phänomen.
Das ist exakt so in Nürnberg auch, ja.
Aber deswegen muss man auch kein guter Trainer sein. Ich nenne es den Floh-Kofeld-Effekt. Grüße nach Darmstadt. Ich lasse mich vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Bitte löscht die Missgabeln wieder. Ich bin ja noch offen, mich umstimmen zu lassen. Aber eine gewisse Grundskepsis bleibt. Ihr zwei, das war sehr, sehr schön, mit euch über die 2. Liga zu sprechen. Wir könnten jetzt auch locker noch eine Stunde weiterreden, aber irgendwann muss man ja auch einfach mal sagen, hier ist jetzt ein Punkt, an dem sind die wichtigsten Dinge gesagt. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Gianni Koster von der Rheinischen Post. Danke dir, Gianni, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Und herzlichen Dank an Fadi Keblawi, die Säule, wenn man über den Club sprechen will. Danke dir, dass du hier warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank.
Und ich danke euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, natürlich auch, denn ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Wenn ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt, dann auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und wenn ihr das bisher noch nicht getan habt, dann probiert es doch mal aus. Es ist gar nicht so schwierig. Und getan haben das unter anderem der Igel, Volker, Felix Jakob, Fabian, Jonathan, Lindy Spindi und Olli. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club gegangen und haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Das geht nämlich auf dieser Seite auch. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Danke, wenn ihr diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt und danke, wenn ihr uns weiter treu bleibt. Es gibt hier noch weitere Sendungen im Rasenfunk in dieser Woche. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.